(Clapping)
- So I already love you, I mean
we all have siblings right?
And that's our relationship
with all of them, but I bet
you all have some pretty
good brother stories.
- Yeah we do.
So, there's five of us
and we're all brothers.
- Five? There's five boys?
- [John] Yes.
- Your poor mother.
(Laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, there's
no other way to say it.
Yup, my poor mom.
- Wow.
I mean, and lucky her, but I
just mean that's a lot of boys.
- Yeah, and we were, how's
the best way for me...
We weren't good kids.
- [Dan] Aggressive, very aggressive.
- Yes we were, there might have been a few
police stops at our house growing up.
- He's like, "I gotta be quiet now".
- You called him out,
he's now calling you out.
- Yeah, we both spent quite a bit of our
youth and adolescense
running from the law.
And one of us was like,
"Man I can out do these guys
so I'm just gonna get involved".
- He ran to them.
- Yeah.
- He done ran to them.
Any stories on Dan?
Like possibly rookie moves
that he thinks he doesn't have
but he did make some rookie moves?
- Ya know, I'm certainly not gonna put him
on the spot in that way.
I'm gonna put him on the
spot in a different way.
And many times when we
get together as a family,
Dan's the only one
involved in law enforcement
and first responding.
And in the few times that
we've had a chance to talk,
he's been able to relay to
us that no matter how hard
we try, he's just seen
and done things that
we'll never be able to actualize.
It makes me feel distant at
points, but at the same time
I love and respect the fact
that he is so dedicated
to his job and his purpose.
That he's honest enough to be
like, "Hey I know you're gonna
try to relate to me on this
level, but what I've seen,
you have no idea what
I go through every day.
And I just wanna be able to lean on
my brothers and sisters
in arms to do that".
So that's kinda--
- Okay, so I'm crying, it's fine.
- That's a difficult speech
for us but it gives me...
I texted him the other day,
we have a very... we grew
up in a man's man house, and its not,
we don't show emotion
that well and all that.
And I've had to learn to
unhardwire those things.
- You're doing a great job.
- Thank you, thank you.
- One thing I truly love
about Dan is he, as much
of the job that is difficult
to digest, he loves his work
and he never once takes it home with him.
And he's a wonderful father,
and a wonderful husband, and
a wonderful brother.
And to be able to manage
all that, I can't even
manage my own life, and for him to be able
to manage all that
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Is super cool.
[Clapping]
- That is so nice.
[Cheers]
- [Kelly] That was so well said.
- I'm very, very grateful
that you asked him to be here.
And literally when your
producers were like,
"We're thinking about maybe
getting your brother Dan".
And I came up with the bit
making fun of me by the way,
because I told him just to go to town.
But I didn't think he would
go, because he's often so
dedicated to his
department and to his work.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think its awesome
that, in meeting a lot of
first responders, in doing this
film that we got coming up,
were gonna talk about it later.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But every so often, whenever
you get to talk to them,
they want their department and they want
their unit showcased, but they never care
to be like, "Hey I did
this" so good on my brother
for doing the bit, but
he's always department
and unit first above all else.
I think that is because,
and forgive me if I'm
speaking out of terms, but in
difficult times, especially
in subject matter that we
can't relate to, you folks
lean on each other.
And I think that's very special.
You have your family,
- [Kelly] A bond.
- and then you have your family.
- Yeah.
- Which is really, really special.
- It's so, so nice.
(Clapping)
- But Dan, actually what's interesting is,
you're not only a first
responder, your life has been
saved by a first responder.
- [John] True.
- Yep.
- [Kelly] What happened?
- Well, back home I worked
for a few different agencies.
And when I was employed for the
town of Newberry, I was just
working after Super Bowl
Sunday, back in 2007.
And I just took a right
onto Route 1 and I started
heading northbound in my cruiser.
I reached 25 miles an
hour and next thing I know
I get hit head on at 76 miles
an hour by a fourth time
drunk driver it took me--
- A fourth time?
- It took me out of the
game for a little while.
That's the picture of what's left of...
that cruiser had about 2,500 miles on it
when I was driving it.
- Wow.
- So yeah, it got banged up pretty bad.
I was very lucky to get
out of there in whatever
shape I'm in now.
It only broke my left leg,
which is pretty amazing
looking at the devastation
done to that car.
And you think it could
have been a lot worse,
if not life ending.
- I'm glad it was only your
leg though, you're right
you got lucky because I saw the car.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- So that is very lucky,
but you were saved
by first responders.
- Absolutely, yeah they were
right down the road from me
and were able to get me
out of my car that was...
I couldn't open the door because
it was crushed in so bad.
So one of the junior guys
actually came running up to me
and ripped the door open.
I went to go put pressure
on my leg to get out,
it just collapsed.
And I said I think I broke my leg.
And he dragged me out, and I broke my leg.
[Kelly] Wow.